bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7 8 à 8
et aujourd'hui cette émission sera
placée sous le signe du sport le
sommaire de votre magazine vendée globe
2016 trois yvelinois s'élanceront des
sables d'olonne le 6 novembre prochain
pour ce tour du monde en solitaire et
sans escale aujourd'hui nous recevrons
l'enfant de rambouillet louis burton il
nous présentera ses objectifs sur cette
compétition
le skipper nous parlera également de son
avenir sur les mers du monde
boxe le boxing club de la verrière vient
de créer une toute nouvelle section dans
sa structure découvre exclusivement
féminin d'aéroboxe un mélange entre
l'aérobic et le sport de combat
deux créneaux animé par une coach
diplômé sont programmées chaque semaine
au gymnase du bois de l'étang vous
entendrez l'entraîneur dans cette
émission on prend tout de suite le large
pour parler du vendée globe 2016 le
départ sera donné des sables d'olonne le
6 novembre prochain le robot litas louis
burton participera à cette épreuve à
bord du bus de bureau vallée nous avons
la chance de recevoir le skipper sur ce
plateau dans ce set 8 invités avec le
directeur de la communication et du
développement de bureau vallée de tirrah
grimmonprez bonsoir messieurs bonsoir
alors on va tout de suite rentré dans le
vif du sujet le 6 novembre ce sera le
départ du vendée globe
comment vous sentez-vous loup burton à
quelques jours du départ c'est vrai que
c'est dans la vie nos mains une très
grosse échéance qui approche est un
petit peu comme
les artistes avant de monter sur scène
on le traque moi je commence
sérieusement à ressentir le trac là
depuis quelques jours un peu plus de mal
à dormir un peu un peu plus de mal à
dormir le matin aussi donc ça fait des
nuits assez courte
vous comprenez ce stress ça thierry oui
oui je le voit différemment par rapport
à la semaine dernière puisque on s'est
déjà vu deux jurys semaine dernière et
effectivement j'ai l'impression qu'il a
une entrée dans sa bulle il est en train
de préparer je sens que je vois dans ses
yeux
donc ce sera votre deuxième vendée globe
vous avez forcément donc un peu plus
d'expérience que lors de votre premier
passage on est à peu près à quinze jours
on va dire à peu près du début de ce
vendée globe
comment gères justement comment gèrent
ces quinze derniers jours avant avant le
début de l'épreuve
j'ai la chance de repartir pour la
deuxième fois sur le vendée globe avec
bureau vallée et du coup de pouvoir
capitaliser sur l'expérience de 2012
l'expérience de 2012 ça a été énormément
de d'énergie en peu de temps et est un
village vendée globe très intense de
trois semaines puisqu'on doit être trois
semaines aux sables-d'olonne en parc
fermé
en voulant voir le maximum de
journaliste le plus de personnes de ma
famille mes amis et c est en fait
j'étais resté pendant les trois semaines
au sable et j'étais arrivé sur ligne de
départ complètement crevé donc on a on a
décidé cette année de faire une première
semaine très chargée
très intensive une deuxième un petit peu
moins c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on
peut être ici sur le plateau de tv fils
donc là je me repose un petit peu et
puis à partir de dimanche à nouveau un
programme très chargé où on a condensé
les contrôles sécu beaucoup de médias
et puis les obligations de la course
quoi donc donc voilà c'est essaye d'être
un petit peu en repos et en même temps
de se concentrer dans la course
il faut éviter peut-être quelques jours
avant les sorties médiatiques ou pas du
tout c'est pas beau de philosophie au
nom le
le fait est que en course au large on
est on est très attendu médiatiquement
sur ces période d'avant-course et sur
les courses c'est d'une part c'est pas
désagréable
c'est fatigant c'est intense mais mais
c'est pas désagréable et on est quand
même avant tout là aussi pour partager
avec le public les fans et c'est donc
non on a on a fait un petit break au
milieu de ces trois semaines mais on a
eu une première semaine très chargée et
la dernière semaine s'annonce
particulièrement intense avec des
journées entre 8 et 12 heures dans une
grosse partie pour les médias thierry il
y a une recette miracle pour préparer à
la compétition ou pas du tout il faut
savoir s'entourer
il faut être avec des gens qu'on aime
il faut cette expérience qu'il a vécu
déjà il ya quatre ans et qui avait été
extrêmement stressante puisqu'on était
quand même sur le tard et je pense que
les quatre années qui viennent de
s'écouler ont professionnaliser louis et
et j'ai discuté un peu avec ses
équipiers c'est extraordinaire la
sérénité qui règne au sein du bateau
lorsqu'on sort bureau vallée accompagne
également
louis burton en dehors de la course pour
préparer cet événement on est
omniprésent on est face on c'est une
histoire
il sourit c'est une histoire d'amitié au
départ et on sait pas qui tu es quoi je
pense qu'il ya pas une journée où on
s'appelle pas au téléphone ce soit avec
nous avec notre pdg vonau pérol et on
est très proche en fait s'il a mal à la
tête on sait s'il ya un truc qui
fonctionne pas on sait voilà c'est une
très très grande cohésion et à quel
moment se dit on va soutenir ce skipper
à quel moment
en fait
c'est vraiment le hasard en fait ça
s'est passé en 2010
on avait un tout petit peu mis un petit
autocollant sur un autre bateau d'un
autre skipper est en fait c'est une
histoire d'amitié entre le père de lui
michel burton et bruno peyroles notre
pdg puisque ils travaillaient ensemble
professionnellement et je me souviendrai
toujours de cette histoire un vendredi
après-midi comité directeur chez bureau
vallée et quand nos paroles me dit il
faut que tu ailles rencontré louis
burton et son père ils ont un projet
faut que tu vois donc je suis allé les
rencontrer les quatre jours après ont
signé un premier accord avec un class 40
et c'est comme ça que ces partis en fait
ça a toujours été comme ça avec lui est
donc pure vallée finances du coup votre
bateau votre bateau justement il est
comment donc dur va les versions 2016
c'est le c'est un monocoque de la classe
imoca qui régit en fait ces bateaux
capables de partir faire le tour du
monde en solitaire
c'est un bateau de 2006 celui avec
lequel je me suis engagé en 2012 et que
l'on a
grâce à ses quatre saisons entre ces
deux vendée globe là qu'ils ont été très
dense puisque on a réalisé deux transat
jacques vabre et une route durant avec
le bateau et des courses d'avant saison
on a travaillé les trois premières
saisons sur la performance quand
ont-elles vraiment pour améliorer la
machine
avec les moyens qui étaient les nôtres
en changeant
en réfléchissant en travaillant sur les
équilibres et ça a été plutôt positif
puisque on est passé d'une septième
place à la jacques vabre en 2011 à une
cinquième place en 2013 est confirmée à
la route du rhum en 2014
et puis on a pour ce vendée globe il a
fait une grosse préparation sur
l'ergonomie du matériel aux skippers à
bord pour que ça soit moins douloureux
pour le pour le marin lutter contre le
froid les bateaux correspond pas
exactement mon âme je vais avoir moins
d'efforts à fournir pour la vie courante
du bateau transportait le matériel sur
les virements de bord etc
faire la veille avant j'étais tout
embrouiller là je suis protégé derrière
une casquette et du coup cette énergie
là elle va pouvoir être mise vraiment
sur la veille sur la performance en tant
que tel et je pars avec bureau vallée
qui est un peu comme une seconde famille
pour moi depuis six ans dans ce
partenariat là et avec un bateau que
j'ai entre les mains depuis cinq ans
donc ce qui fait de nous le trio le plus
vieux et le plus fidèle de ce vendée
globe
donc vous nous promettez que le bateau
sera compétitif alors le bateau est un
bateau qui est compétitif par rapport à
sa génération
c'est un peu comme dans d'autres sports
mécaniques il ya des des bateaux de
toute dernière génération qui ont qui
coûte très cher etc qui eux sont a
priori sur le papier les leaders puis
ensuite il ya un peloton dans lequel
nous on se situait à gurs vallée avec
comme avantage pour nous d'être fiable
d'avoir un bateau qui est éprouvée qui a
fini toutes ses courses hormis ce vendée
globe 2012 sur une suite à une collision
qui était pas lié à un problème
technique et sur un le vendée globe on
sait qu'il y a à peu près un skipper sur
deux qui arrive 50 % de la flotte qui
malheureusement abandonné donc le fait
d'avoir un bateau fiable permet de vous
avez abandonné d'ailleurs sur sur la
dernière édition
ou est ce la dernière édition mer sur
une collision sur les collisions et on a
aussi beaucoup de coureurs qui
abandonnent sur des cases technique et
nous on a vraiment souhaité travailler
sur cette partie là pour bat pour mettre
tous ces problèmes là de côté dans la
mesure du possible
thierry un bateau comme celui qui va
être utilisé pour le vendée globe coûte
cher quelles sont les retombées pour
votre image de marque nous mesure
toujours
au delà de l'amitié de l'exploit sportif
on mesure toujours le retour de
notoriété donc on passe par une
entreprise d'études qui s'appelle ipsos
et on mesura après chaque grande course
l'évolution de notre indice de notoriété
et à chaque fois on fait un bond en
avant
on prend entre quatre et cinq points
d'amélioration en termes de notoriété et
qui seront les favoris de l'épreuve
selon vous louis burton partie des
favoris non non non je ne fais pas
partie des favoris
ma sur cette émission omnium classement
on a là on a le sentiment qu'on est
considéré comme comme un team qui a qui
fait partie des favoris pour arriver on
est ressenti comme ça et c'est bien
parce que c'est vraiment là dessus qu'on
a travaillé et puis c'est notre objectif
commun les favoris après d'un point de
vue sportif
armel le cléac'h sur banque populaire il
a deux vendée globe derrière lui deux
fois deuxième
donc que ces expériences oui et puis
c'est pas un garçon qui aime la place de
second
donc il a un très bon bateau une bonne
préparation beaucoup de talent il je
pense qu'il est considéré on peut
considérer comme le favori et ensuite on
a comme ça si bateau affole donc avec
ces plants porteurs qui permettent de
soulager la coque qui vont plus vite
qu'ils ont encore pas tous le trouver en
termes de fiabilité mais qui vont plus
vite donc ces bateaux là si s'ils
rencontrent pas d'embûches techniques
sont théoriquement devant et ensuite il
ya des très très bon bateau aussi de la
génération précédente avec vincent riou
sur prb qui est très abouti avec sm à
qui paul meilhat qui en fait a le le
bateau victorieux de l'édition 2012 qui
lui aussi fait partie des je pense des
personnes potentiellement sur le podium
dernière question avant de refermer
cette interview est ce que vous avez un
message à faire passer aux rambolitains
rapidement oui oui un message à faire
passer aux robes en utah et puis à tous
les habitants de ce qu'on l'a des
yvelines
accrochez vous à vos rêves moi j'ai
grandi dans la forêt de rambouillet et
depuis les champs dans lesquels on joue
et je rêvais d'océan et puis voilà et
aujourd'hui grâce à toutes ces
rencontres et à toutes ces belles
histoires
j'y suis mon deuxième vendée globe donc
accrochez vous à vos rêves merci à tous
les deux d'être passé sur ce plateau
louis burton bon courage pour ce vendée
globe 2016 je vous avoue que je n'aurais
pas eu le courage de partir en solitaire
comme vous on vous souhaite de terminer
la course et de terminer le plus haut
possible merci encore on ouvre à présent
une page boxe le boxing club de
l'aveyron vient de créer une toute
nouvelle section dans sa structure qui
courra exclusivement féminin d'aéroboxe
un mélange entre l'aérobic et le sport
de combat
deux créneaux animé par une coach
diplômé sont ouverts le lundi de 14
heures à 15 heures le vendredi de 18
heures à 19 heures au gymnase du bois de
l'étang présentation de secours par
l'entraîneur de la section lucide
lefebvre mouvements de boxe en musique
sans opposition dont il y a personne
derrière qu'il va venir vous frappez
donc on savait vite les bleus qu'on a
sur le visage après donc on a une partie
d'échauffement encore de séance
du renforcement musculaire et étirements
et pourquoi avoir créé un cours
exclusivement pour les filles moi parce
que c'est une demande en fait de se
retrouver entre femmes
ça change un peu et les filles ça leur
plaît la boxe oui oui je pense que pour
certains du coup il y avait une
appréhension
du coup avec le monde de la boxe et
l'aéroboxe en fait part mais déjà de
mettre un pied dans la salle de boxe et
après peut-être qui sait devenir faire
des cours de boxe anglaise et est-ce
qu'il faut des qualités particulières
pour s'inscrire secours à ce cours
d'aéroboxe non pas du tout quelqu'un qui
veut reprendre une activité physique un
peu qu'un complètement venir en cours et
est ce qu'il y a un effet j e on a vu la
france briller aux jo avec avec la boxe
et notamment les filles est ce qu'il ya
un effet j'ai hoché chez les féminines 1
là je sais que pour les inscriptions
dans les cours de boxe anglaise ya en
effet j'ai donc on a beaucoup plus
d'adhérents qui se présentent dans nos
salles donc à ça soit la verrière ou à
marly-le-roi aimé l'aéroboxe je peux pas
vous dire encore que ça un effet jumeaux
parce que c'est quand même pas la même
chose en fait
et la verrière pourvoi la verrière c'est
lancer vraiment dans des cours
exclusivement féminin féminin abbas et
on sait le coach hassan qui est venu qui
m'a en a parlé ce que je viens de faire
la formation en fait donc c'est ma
première année en tant qu'animatrice
aéroboxe et du coup on a eu il a eu
l'idée créer une section pour les femmes
à l'intérieur parce que c'était une
demande qui pouvait y avoir et moi ça me
plaisait aussi de d'être dans ce projet
en fait voilà de créer un espace pour
les femmes entre nous et ça change un
peu et si vous inscrire comme en fait il
faut juste venir
donc du coup pendant les pendant les
séances où on leur donne les papiers ou
sinon faut venir le soir ici à la
verrière demandé à hassan et on leur
donne les papiers pour l'inscription
ce qu'il nous faut obligatoirement un
certificat médical c'est quand même
économiser
c'est la fin de cette 8 invités merci
d'avoir suivi très belle soirée sur tv
fil 78